this Saturday just up the 405 at the
forum and Inglewood California it is a
heavyweight Grand Prix that that
includes a double main event but it is
Chael Sonnen versus Rampage Jackson good
to see jail back here on the show how
you doing brother I'm doing good the
fights that heavyweight first time ever
at heavyweights so no weight cut usually
when I see you I'm just rest that I'm
trying to lose weight and I'm
dehydrating but this time I am about 45
pounds underweight you are yes okay no
stress okay no stress and thus that
leads into the four pack revolution this
book about how you can cheat on your
diet still lose weight and keep it off
by Chael Sonnen right here you say
you're trying to gain weight is what
you're trying to do I'm trying to kind
of just stay steady but I I would have
weight - game yeah if I gain too much
weight I slow down and I get tired and
you know so I try to uh try to just be
optimal I'm more more optimal around
2:15 okay then I am at 265 so you want
something to eat here know what the fat
but very nice of you but the fact that I
could have something if I were hungry
isn't is a nice feeling it isn't right
Betty
you must be it's the worst part of the
process is is you know that there's two
fights for us I don't think there's
another job in the world where your boss
weighs you in before he let you go to
work it's a very unique thing and that
battle is so hard I mean I've been as
much as 17 pounds over 24 hours before
weigh-in and just the depression of
having to get that off and not having to
go through that yeah I thought I thought
I should bring it up to you I thought it
was a conversation it's kind of funny
like was [ __ ] maybe they should make
people in my business do that just to
weigh in before going on TV TV adds 10
pounds you add 10 pounds that's right on
or we should have a press conference
after our show after the show yeah I
just thought like that second hour I
just didn't have it just try to get
through that segment I don't know if I
was able to do it I apologize to the
fans shutting down interview that I had
in the second hour well in your cast
with ice over your neck yeah yeah that
would be really good or or I just come
on with a hoodie on and I just you know
I you know I just next question yeah
like you don't have time for this
why in the hell you're 40 years old
correct correct why in the hell are you
getting into an octagon with any other
human before t years young man I I love
it just the same I
I retired at one point a few years ago
and that was so great for about two
weeks and I didn't know what to do with
my time and my social life is largely
going to practice seeing the guys going
to the gym no and I thought me know I'm
just gonna ride this out I don't want to
leave anything on the table I did that
in my amateur days I wanted to be an
Olympian and and I came up short and I
have so many regrets for not trying just
one more tournament one more year one
more season I'm not gonna make that
mistake again
right and so what is your family's say
about this well I mean they love it
they're very supportive I came from a
family of wrestlers my uncle's my
cousins my father and everybody so
uh-huh you know you only gonna be alive
for so long rich if you can do what you
love for for 40 or 50 years you got to
take a shot at it right and so Rampage
Jackson is the the the shot that you're
taking rampages next yeah we're in a
tournament so this is the first round of
the quarterfinals right whoever advances
between rampage and I will move on to
the semifinals and ultimately it will
culminate through over this calendar
year and and whoever's left standing
Coker is gonna put the belt around
called world champion right who's a
better talker your or rampage I love
listening to rampage I've always enjoyed
rampage I get asked that question a lot
between a fighter named Conor McGregor
and myself and I always say you guys are
leaving one out you're leaving out
rampage the original charismatic fighter
mm-hmm so but that's a mouth you'd like
to shut up is what you're saying I got
no choice diplomacy has failed I offered
him a way out all you had to do was
surrender and forfeit the match and let
me advance but you chose not to
now we're gonna fight even that I again
a 40-year old getting in there and doing
all that no matter how many miles the
car has rich it's how many miles the car
has left can I should I write that down
that's a good one yeah I like that
Chael Sonnen here on the Rich Eisen show
getting set to take on Rampage Jackson
this weekend speaking of McGregor when
the hell is he getting back in you know
let's see if he does I Dana White came
out in our press conference on Sunday I
don't know if you saw it and he said
that McGregor III must have missed that
amongst the the steelers and jaguars the
other one so What did he say
well he just said Conor is out until
September at the earliest if he's even
coming back and he said you know unless
he changes his mind I'm paraphrasing now
but unless he changes his mind in a
hurry I'm gonna strip him stripped him
of his title and I
that's the situation he's in and I
thought it's a wise maneuver yeah I do I
do for many reasons one it's the right
thing to do if a guy doesn't defend
within 12 months he's eligible to be
stripped Connors pulling up on the
two-year mark later this year and
secondly it's a better storyline you're
much better to strip a guy and bring him
back if you're talking from a business
perspective it's a much more intriguing
storyline that Conor McGregor turns to
recapture the title that he never lost
in the first place so yes strip him so
do you think McGregor's willingly
playing into this you think that that's
the the way that they're going about
this maybe you know I think that
McGregor made 100 million dollars
against Floyd he did yeah and it's just
going man I don't know if I want to do
this again you know to the point you're
asking me I'm 40 days 28 years old and I
think he just wants to enjoy his life
that's my guess I I haven't spoke to him
I offered to hire him when the mob was
gonna kill him I got a place I said man
you could come stay there but I never
talked fighting with it I don't know I
said well how is he not have just been
in a Guy Ritchie movie already and just
and the suspense just go in just just to
start acting he'd do so well
he really would he's known as mad at guy
he's got plenty of other options isn't
that what he wants to do I probably I
think he does I think he wants to be out
there and stay active but he is he's a
real fighter he has an ego and a pride
and anyone's to represent his team and
his family in his country and you know
it's not just all about the money for
him so then who's the next one you know
I mean don't you need somebody of his
stature to continue the sports ascension
you could certainly use somebody I mean
those guys are hard to come by you know
getting a connor that can captivate you
know not only his own country but other
country is a very rare thing but yeah it
can happen overnight the landscape
changes so fast who would you tag who
would you peg for that well let's see I
mean they got a guy named in gone oh
this is gonna fight for a heavyweight
championship soon I think that he could
he could grab that torture and run with
it I don't know the same at Conor a
little bit different but you know not
everybody's the rock you've also got
Stone Cold Steve Austin in there it
doesn't have to be the same thing so
let's see
but those up and comers come out there's
a guy named Kevin Lee doing a lot of
things right we got a guy named Douglas
Leeman Saturday that if if he beats Rory
MacDonald I think that's gonna be his
big breakthrough moment - and could
almost sudden be a box-office star right
it happens really quickly all the
promoter can do is set the table
it's up to the athlete to take take it
from there Chael Sonnen here on the Rich
Eisen show again
formerly spiked the paramount Network at
9:00 Eastern Time coming up this
Saturday on tickets on sale at
Ticketmaster dot-com if you're in the
area to go to the forum to check out
Bellator 192 featuring jail and Rampage
Jackson coming up on Saturday night
I have not I've noticed you and Chuck
Liddell have kind of gone back and forth
on social media in a way yeah he's on
the show tomorrow
very good would you like to leave him a
note I could dictate it no that's I've
got a I've got a blank sheet of paper
right here in front of me yeah I will
tell you this Chuck seems to be a very
nice guy he's got a good reputation I
hear he treats people well he's got a
walk around town with a haircut that
looks like he lost a bet and I wish
Chuck the best should I write that down
and you can I don't know if he could
read it it's not dictating it for me
there's the fact that you'd have to read
it to him and then and then explain it
beyond that but mmm no I don't have any
business with Chuck he had flirted with
the idea that he was gonna come back and
so he was in my crosshairs but but he's
not coming back so there you go at least
not yet I could try and I could try and
spur a comeback yeah see what you can do
there okay yeah that'd be fun but you're
saying I'd have to speak it out to him
you Prive to speak it out slowly yeah
just slow it down you slow it down you
know I mean you know wish him well come
on help the guy out oh my gosh the
four-pack revolution let's talk about
this Jill what is it all right
revolution that's gonna teach you
everything from recipes in there to
suggestions of exercise but above
everything else it's a mindset the
dirtiest word in losing weight rich is
time it doesn't happen overnight you got
to change your lifestyle you got to
change your mindset I don't believe in
going on diets
I believe in changing your eating habits
and it's all in the book it's all in the
book um do I have to give up my red wine
no really you do not have to give up red
wine coach it's just not copious amounts
of red ones just not copious amounts yes
moderate you see are you telling you
moderation is all you're telling I think
that would work yes you know one class
one class tonight
before I let you go you said you wanted
to talk about this football stuff that
we were talking about the school I just
don't love it me if I was to get into
football I would change so many things I
mean all the way down to the way they
come on a field they're there's nothing
in life it's basic bye they come on the
field they're all amped up and there's
no sport in the world where an athlete
behaves like that it's basic biology
whatever is red-hot can only cool
down any good athlete from LeBron -
Tiger to Mayweather on down you walk out
there calm once they say go that's where
you use your energy but I want to speak
on this point I like the days because
don't forget sports are for kids and if
you're lucky enough to do it as an adult
you're just that you're lucky enough I
like the mindset where coach where
athletes still call their coach mister
and followed by his last name I like the
mindset where it's not about the money
and it's about the fame it's about
respect it's about trying to have more
points than the other guy when time runs
out and when I see an athlete that is
supposed to be a leader turn on his
coach um it's military policy right
everybody's got their chain that come
here the coach sits at the very top you
just don't disrespect your coach
so you're thinking Big Ben's doing that
by talking about the the sneaks publicly
yeah yeah I think that that was private
information he should have taken up with
Tomlin but ultimately it's Tomlin's call
it's not Ben's : he should it be he
should it be put him down to the media
that was my opinion
Chael Sonnen at Chael Sonnen on twitter
again Bellator 192 um coming up this
Saturday against Rampage Jackson and the
four pack revolution how you can aim low
or cheat on your diet and still lose
weight and keep it off available right
now as it was released earlier this
month you have to sign this copy for me
spoiler alert rich yes jail wins jail
wins I like it I like it and I'll tell
Chuck you said hello tell me I said I
okay that's Chael Sonnen here on the
rich eyes and show your phone calls and
more back and sick tell I've been
looking for him ice the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience